الان الى اخر التطورات بشان حرب روسيا على
اوكرانيا حيث اعلنت القياده المركزيه
الامريكيه انا واشنطن نقلت اكثر من مليون
طلقه من الذخيره الايرانيه التي تمت
مصادراتها الى اوكرانيا واوضحت القياده
المركزيه في بيان ان هذه الذخائر صدرت في
ديسمبر من العام الماضي بعدما كانت موجهه
من الحرس الثوري الايراني الى الحوثيين في
اليمن واكدت القياده التزام واشنطن بالعمل
مع حلفائها وشركائها لمواجهه تدفق
المساعدات الايرانيه الفتاكه في المنطقه
بجميع الوسائل المشروعه واضافت ان دعم
ايران للجماعات المسلحه يهدد الامن
الدوليه والاقليمي والقوات الامريكيه
والدبلوماسيين الامريكيين في المنطقه
وانها ستواصل بدل كل ما في وسعها لتسليط
الضوء على انشطه ايران المزعزعه للاستقرار
ووقفها حسب تعبير البيان
انه الينا الان من واشنطن مراسا الجزيره
احمد هزيم احمد في صوره ما جاء ايضا من
تفاصيل في بيان القياده المركزيه
الامريكيه فيما يتعلق بهذه الطلقات
الايرانيه ولماذا اعلنت عنها الان
ذاهبه للحوثيين تسلمها لاوكرانيا في
محاوله للسد فجوه حاجه اوكرانيا لهذا
النوع من الذخائر خصوصا في ظل الجدل
السياسي هنا في الولايات المتحده في
الكونجرس والذي ادى الى تمديد مشروع
الانفاق لمده 45 يوم دون تضمينه اموالا
مخصصه لتزويد اوكرانيا بالسلاح هذا ربما
ما دفع الولايات المتحده الى استخدام هذه
هذه هذا السبيل لتزويد ايران عفوا تزويد
اوكرانيا بالذخيره حتى يتم انقضاء الجدل
الدائر في الكونجرس حول المساعدات التي
تقدمها الولايات المتحده لاوكرانيا
البيان بيان القياده الوسطى ايضا شدد بن
اولاد المتحده ستظل تتابع انشطه ايران او
مسمته وانشطه ايران الخبيثه في المنطقه
وستواصل تطبيق قرارات مجلس الامن الدولي
اي بمعنى حظر توريد السلاح لجماعه
الحوثيين في اليمنية احمد هزيم مراسى
جزيره كنت معنا من واشنطن شكرا لك